des rats qui se promènent tranquillement
dans les rues de Montréal et en plein
jour ils sont plusieurs à avoir remarqué
leur présence dans certains quartiers
le nombre de rats aussi réent entre 5 à
6 millions dans la métropole selon
l'industrie de la gestion parasitaire
qui affirme avoir vu les demandes pour
des exterminations quadruplées en 2022
par rapport aux années précédentes pour
tenter de venir à bout de ses rongeurs
la ville permet à nouveau l'utilisation
d'un rhodonticide interdit l'an dernier
on doit agir parce que on voit qu'il y a
quelque chose qui se passe certains
comme lui tirent la sonnette d'alarme il
faut un plan d'intervention notamment
une meilleure gestion des déchets c'est
des interventions des idées qu'on donne
aux citoyens parce qu'il doit y avoir
une campagne de communication aussi aux
citoyens il fut un exemple
alors que le nombre de plaintes a
augmenté de près de 70% en 4 ans New
York même des spécialistes en gestion
parasite qui sont engagés par la ville
puis c'est des employés de la file la
multiplication des chantiers de
construction n'est pas non plus
étrangère au phénomène
c'est vrai que les rats on les voit
peut-être de plus en plus mais c'est par
secteur c'est ciblé l'opposition demande
d'ailleurs à la ville de dératiser
systématiquement lors de travaux du côté
de la ville on assure que tout est fait
pour empêcher leur prolifération
pourquoi on répare les égouts entre
autres pour éviter la présence de
brèches qui facilite l'accès sur la rue
à la population de rock tout en
demandant la participation des monts
réalistes
si le rôle a le choix entre un poison
aura un piège une pointe de pizza c'est
la fin des pizzas qui va gagner la
population de rongeurs tant en tout cas
à augmenter au fil des années le
réchauffement climatique favorisant
reproduction cohabitation ou éradication
le sort réservé aura continuera de
diviser ici Camille Faye zen
Radio-Canada Montréal